so let's get some practice simplifying
polynomials especially in the case where
we have more than one variable over here
so i have 4x squared y
minus 3x squared minus 2y so all that
entire expression plus the entire
expression 8xy minus 3x squared plus 2x
squared y plus 4.
so the first thing that jumps out at me
is that i'm just adding this expression
to this expression so to a large degree
these parentheses don't matter so i can
just rewrite it as four x squared y
minus three x squared
minus two y
plus
eight x y
minus three x squared plus two x squared
y plus 4.
now we can try to group similar terms or
like terms so let's think about what we
have over here so this first term right
over here is a 4 x squared
y
so can i add this to any of the other
terms here do we have any other x
squared y terms
well sure this one right over here is
another x squared y term
if i have 4 of something in this case i
have 4 x squared y's and i add two x
squared y's to it how many x squared y's
do i now have
well four plus two i have i now have six
x squared
six x squared y's
now let's move on to this term so i have
negative three x x squareds do i have
any other more do i have any more x
squareds in this expression right over
here
well sure i have another negative three
x squared so if i have negative 3 of
something and then i have a nugget
they're negative 3 i end up with
negative 6 of that thing so it's
negative 6
x squared
now let's think about this negative 2 y
term are there any other y's over here
well it doesn't look like there are this
is an 8xy this is a 4. there's no just
y's so i can't really add that to
anything so i'll just rewrite it
negative 2y
and then
8xy
well once again doesn't seem like that
can be added to anything else so let's
just write that over again
and then finally we just have the
constant term
plus four and it pretty much looks like
we're done we have simplified this as
much
as much as we can